شكرًا لك
[موسيقى]
الحساسية البيئية التي يمكن أن
تتطور بشكل جيد إلى مرحلة البلوغ ونعم
يمكن أن تتغير طوال حياتك ،
لذا يعد الآن أحد مواسم حبوب اللقاح
لشجرة اللقاح ولكن في وقت لاحق
في الربيع هناك حبوب لقاح العشب
ولا يدرك الناس ذلك  لكن الخريف هو
موسم كبير للحساسية الموسمية لأن
الرجويد في الهواء
لدينا جميع مرضانا يبدأون
الأدوية الوقائية في وقت مبكر من
الموسم خاصة إذا كنت مصابًا بالربو
لأن ذلك قد يهدد الحياة ، فهم
يعملون بشكل أفضل إذا بدأتهم
قبل ظهور الأعراض.  لقد
اشتعلت بالفعل الآن عادةً في شهر مارس ، لكن هذا
العام كان لدينا أشخاص يعانون من
أعراض حتى في وقت مبكر من فبراير ، إنها
أشياء بسيطة يمكنك القيام بها أيضًا
لتقليل تعرضك لحبوب اللقاح ، لذلك نوصي دائمًا
بإبقاء النوافذ مغلقة
خلال ذروة مواسم حبوب اللقاح  إذا كنت في
الخارج ، فأنت تعلم أنه يمكنك
ارتداء قناع فعليًا ، وبعد ذلك عندما تعود إلى المنزل ،
نوصي دائمًا بتغيير
ملابسك والاستحمام وشطف
حبوب اللقاح الملتصقة بك
وبجسمك لأنك ستحضرها
معك إلى المنزل.  وإحضاره إلى السرير معك
واستمر في الاستجابة له طوال الليل ،
فهناك الكثير من
الأدوية الرائعة التي لا تستلزم وصفة طبية أيضًا ،
تعمل مضادات الهيستامين التي تعمل على مدار 24 ساعة عادةً بشكل أفضل
من شيء مثل Benadryl ، لذا فإن بعض
مضادات الهيستامين التي تعمل على مدار 24 ساعة مثل Claritin
Zyrtec Allegra zyzal  لأنها تدوم لفترة
أطول لواحد وأن مضادات
الهيستامين الأحدث لها آثار جانبية أقل
مثل النعاس والأشياء الأخرى
المرتبطة به والآن الكثير من
قطرات العين الجيدة وبخاخات الأنف لا تحتاج إلى
وصفة طبية أيضًا ولكن
الشيء الذي سأبقى فيه  بعيدًا عن
الاستخدام المطول ، على الرغم من أنه لا يحتاج إلى
وصفة طبية ، فهو مزيلات الاحتقان ، إلا أنه يمكن أن يتسبب في
حدوث عادات ويسبب آثارًا جانبية أخرى ،
ويمكن أن يرفع
ضغط الدم لديك ويزيد من معدل ضربات القلب ،
ويمكن حتى إخفاءه في دواء الحساسية الخاص بك ،
لذا فإن أي شيء به علامة
لا ينبغي حقًا استخدام أكثر من
أسبوع أو نحو ذلك ،
فنحن على وشك إجراء اختبار حساسية والطريقة التي
يعمل بها هي أننا نخدش
سطح الجلد بجميع المواد
المسببة للحساسية المختلفة ، أقترح الذهاب إلى
أخصائي الحساسية إذا دعنا نقول
الأدوية التي لا تستلزم وصفة طبية لا
تعمل كما تعلم أو تعاني من أي نوع من
مشاكل التنفس ،
يمكن لأخصائي الحساسية المعتمد من مجلس الإدارة اختبارك
للتأكد من أنه مصاب بالحساسية ثم
يقدم أيضًا المشورة في أوقات أخرى من
العام حيث قد تواجهك مشاكل  أيضًا